[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale leçon pour débutants avec le
maître international nino maso ratzé
bonjour ni nos jours alors aujourd'hui
on va voir une soirée très importante
aux échecs notamment si on veut lire des
livres sur le jeu d'échecs ou voir même
des commentaires de partie sur internet
s'il y en a beaucoup les beaucoup de
sites qui explique les parties d'échecs
sur internet donc là de façon écrite non
pas en vidéo mais nego nantes et on va
comprendre comment on peut noter une
partie d'échecs tout ça c'est très
important veut lire une partie d'échecs
très important exactement c'est comme
donner pas savoir lire
voilà donc on vous apprend à lire aux
échecs entre guillemets c'est que
s'appelle notation et après
indépendamment ou pourriez déjà donc les
spectateurs de peut-être aller
indépendamment acheter les livres des
chèques et ou sur les commentaires et
ses erreurs et s'est débrouillé tout
seul voilà donc une façon après de voir
des commentaires des chèques sur sur
papier dans le journaux s'il y en a
beaucoup de journaux qui commentent des
positions d'échecs avec des parties
entièrement écrite et bien il s'agit de
savoir décoder ce langage un peu
mystérieux ça vous ouvre la porte
partout voilà alors on va voir un
exemple on va vous montrer qu'être le
début de partie on va voir comment on
peut noter
une partie d'échecs au mans on note les
coups alors on a ici musique évidemment
dans la position initiale alors vous
voyez juste au dessus de mon image on
vous a mis en gros la notation qui
apparaît souvent dans des zones à la
télé on vous met la notation en petit
mont mais là on a mis un peu plus gros
pour que vous puissiez la voir alors on
va rappeler qu'en mai quelque chose
d'évident
c'est que l'échiquier il est repéré par
huit colonnes et 800 g alors les
colonnes c'est ce qu'on appelle ici ça
c'est la colonne a donc ici la colonne a
ensuite b c d e f g h
donc ça on appelle ça les colonnes de as
donc jusqu'à h les colonnes ce notre
instinct et les rangées sont notées ici
donc comme à la bataille navale comme
ici comme 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 donc ça c'est
important
voilà donc les ranger un autre 4 6 et 8
ici vers le haut donc les noirs sont
toujours sur les rangées 7 et 8 et les
blancs sur les rangées 1 et 2 au départ
c'est toujours comme ça et a b c d e f g
h
donc ça c'est important alors après une
fois qu'on connaît ça eh bien on peut
noter une partie d'échecs alors comment
comment on va expliquer c'est comment
est déjà bien sûr il faut connaître les
noms des pièces comme vous pouvez voir
les autres coureurs de stéphane - si
vous ne savez pas encore donc en général
on apprendre le première lettre de
dénomination d'une pièce par exemple
cavaliers ce sera tout simplement
grancey ont écrit en grandes lettres par
exemple le roi ce sera m dante et sert à
la tomate et on l'apprend pas confondre
avec les cases par exemple des comme
pour dames
on pourrait confondre avec la case sur
la colonne des on va mettre en grande et
voilà c'est pour ça aussi ça facilite
pas ce qu'est en grand et en plus ça va
aux premières et à savoir donc tous les
pièces antoine marques comme ça comme le
fouet f
mais le pion les pions ils n'ont pas de
ne pas on ne marque pas peine par
exemple moi papy pour le vol à voile a
donc annulé rien ça veut dire que savait
le pion ça veut dire c'est un pion là
alors soit il ya une
une grande lettre de bain dont tu es bon
tour c'est pour cavaliers f pour fou des
bourdes am r pour roy ou alors si rien
devant et bien déjà
c'est un pion voilà déjà comme ça on
détermine la pièce qui va bouger
mais attention parce que dans tous les
pays c'est lettre sert à différentes
c'est pas très déterminante au sens où
quand nous indique les cases en général
il n'y a pas 36 pis non plus qui va sur
cette case bien sûr donc ça vous est
déjà pas mal de deviner si ces marques
r3 par exemple quelle équipe y aller par
exemple vous voyez un anglais et
d'ailleurs je crois en anglais ici donc
en anglais ce sera les autres
dénominations ou angus notre maison chez
un autre titre donc
savary savary par rapport au lait tous
les pays
quoi d'autre il faut vous dire également
qu'elle il y a deux façons de notation à
l'ancien et nouveau plu raccourci c'est
qu'ils étaient nos jours plus utilisés
on appelle sa notation algébrique je ne
sais pas si c'est algérie d'accord et
donc en quoi il consiste alors oui donc
on a parlé cette lettre devant
évidemment ça va dépendre de la langue
ici en l'occurrence c'est vrai que
l'exemple et en est en anglais mais
enfin nous a dit les lettres en français
c'est ça qui compte si vous lisez des
livres en français mais elle a beaucoup
d'anglais et messieurs on donne donc le
nom de le la de la pièce devant syrien
donc c'est un pion et ensuite on à la
case d'arrivée tout simplement pas
arrivé on donnerait pas la caisse de
douai c'est ça que j'ai parlé méthode en
sciences il s'agissait il marquait
d'abord le case de départ
et avec tiré après le case d'arrivée bon
là mais c'était plus long oui c'était
très long par exemple ici on peut déjà
pas d'être commencer une démonstration
là on remarque par exemple vous voyez
juste 4 donc ici on la voit on voit que
la notation ici alors il ya le numéro du
cookie et devant donc très bruyant
meurent les gourous il ya le coût des
blancs donc notée par une seule case
donc ça veut dire que c'est un pion n'y
a pas de
grosses lettres devant le 4 le 1 ses
premiers coups après deux deuxièmes
coups etc
1e cat donc ici on voit bien que c'est
le pion qui va sur la case de quatre il
ya un accueil qui peut jouer sur la case
de graz évidemment c'est celui ci donc
oui on devine vite lequel ses anciennes
notation on mettait eu deux ans 24 ya
encore des liens avec thierry avec un
petit tir et au milieu pour pour séparer
le coût des blancs jaunes et noirs il
faut pas que vous vous étonnez si vous
voyez dans un livre quelque chose comme
et d'eau et 4 avec les tigres et voilà
où pertes qu'est ce que ça veut dire
voilà ça veut dire tout simplement c'est
un livre ancien c'est un livre ancien
muer en cours des récentes qui fonce à
autrui aussi il ya les amateurs qui est
une question de choix
troisième choix mais en fait donc la
même notation algébrique simplifier
c'est celle ci c'est la plus commune
donc pas de
pas de case de départ juste la case
arrivée donc voilà donc on va voir un
exemple ici avec tous les exemples qu'on
peut voir donc eu quatre on a bougé le
pion sur la case de 4 les noirs répondre
gardé par le coup eux cinq donc 2,5
c'est un pion n'est pas de l'être devant
donc la case de 5 c'est celle ci donc le
seul pion qui peut bouger c'est celui là
donc effectivement paf e5 c'est bien le
pion qui vient sur la case de 5 alors on
arrive au cou numéro 2 c'est au blanc de
jouer alors qu ça va bien d'ici de queen
pour nous il ne rennes en anglais il ya
1,6 était notée en notation française ça
serait un grand d mon but c'est pareil
on fait vite la différence de toute
façon il vaut mieux ça virtual anglais
d'ailleurs poussé le plus le plus commun
qu'est les logiciels est plutôt en
anglais en général prévente en tout cas
et les livres aussi il y en a beaucoup
en anglais en fait qu ou dame ou qui
louent des de toute façon on peut pas se
tromper
q pourquoi alors la dame sauvegarde
hamissi donc sur la case h5 alors h5 a b
c d e f g h c'est bien la dernière
colonie 6 1 2 3 4 5 c'est cette case
effectivement la dame ici peut venir sur
cette case donc le coup c'est dommage 5
alors on note ici ni non qu'est ce que
c'est que ça on voit un point
d'interrogation suivie d'un point
d'exclamation quelles seraient les
signes des chèques donc c'est aussi
important à savoir qu'air parfois au
lieu de commander par les mots pour
raccourcir aussi donc en
7 commentaires ont nommé lessines ici
pour une interrogation point
d'exclamation signifie un coût du taux
général coups douteux
c'est ça ça veut dire que c'est un coût
qui considérait comme papa super
forcément pas très bon quoi mais c'est
c'est pas tout à fait mauvais non plus
voilà et c'est entre ses seins trop les
deux voilà en tout cas c'est pas un bon
coup c'est sûr alors si c'était un
mauvais coup tout simplement il y aurait
un poney clame un point d'interrogation
oui donc ça c'est à retenir pour nos
spectateurs un point d'interrogation ça
signifie un mauvais coup de poing dans
dérogations très très mauvais coup ça
c'est quand ça démarre par un point
d'interrogation c'est que c'est mauvais
oui ça peut être pondérée par un point
d'exclamation parce que là ça veut dire
pas trop mauvais mais mauvais quand même
ça peut être un seul point
d'interrogation dans ce cas là c'est
mauvais et deux points d'interrogation
là par contre c'est très mauvais ce cas
sachez qu'elle est trois points
d'interrogation n'existait pas voilà ni
trois points d'exclamation et les six
mois jusqu'à d'austin dillon al'inverse
du point d'eau à l'air d'interrogation
c'est le point d'exclamation qui lui
veut dire plutôt un bon coup donc s'il
ya un point d'exclamation suivie d'un
point d'interrogation c'est un coup
qu'on appelle intéressant mais pas
franchement bon mais plutôt bon plutôt
bon oui et c'est ce qu'on est en général
quant à elie parfois ces nouveautés au
parfois c'est un coup intéressant qu
intéressante voilà un coût qui demande à
être creusé ensuite un point
d'exclamation tout seul ça veut dire
beaucoup
wynn et deux points d'exclamation très
bons coups c'est excellent voilà un coup
aux excellents alors ici donc on a
affaire à un coût qui est considéré
comme douteux parce que on sort pas trop
la dame au début en général c'est pas
bon alors on voit le coup suivant en
fait ici je vais passer directement au
coût de 2 qui est marqué ici
enfin qu'ils aient marqué plus bas on ne
voit pas sur l'écran parce que il est en
dessous c'est le temps ici il faudrait
qu'on puisse le voir sur l'écran je sais
pas si on peut nous mettre l'image en
haut plutôt que de la mettre en bas à la
régie
voilà merci donc ici voit on voit le
deuxième coup ici deuxième coup des
noirs en fait c'est le coup deux d'en
regarder
alors qu'est ce que c'est c'est 3
pointillés nino avait ça aussi donc
quand on analyse les parties parfois on
ouvre les parenthèses d'ailleurs vous
voyez exemptés par un taiseux c'est
juste ici par exemple qu'est fermer ici
fermé donc si on remonte au début il
faudrait que par contre il
voilà la parenthèse a été ouverte ici on
voit très bien
donc après le coup deuxième coup des
blancs donc on reprend après deux
principales voilà la variante principal
on verra sur la parenthèse après donc 2
on revient au cou numéro 2 c au nord de
jouer ici
voilà si on her de jouer donc 2 3e set
et leurs deux points d'interrogation
qu'est ce que ça signifie
c'est une fille quand on me disait que
c'est très très mauvais coup très
mauvais coup c'est une gaffe et pourquoi
c'est une gaffe et on va le voir par le
coup suivant était dans prend 1,5 et ses
maths alors c'est matt howard et ses
marques et le math par ce petit sigle
ici dans des dièses donc dame prend on
voit bien dans prend la case de cinq
dames prend alors ici prendre c'est le
multipliez ça c'est important à noter
aussi donc multiplier ici ça veut dire
prends oui et à sandrine piau m'ont
appris le pion dans certains livres
monde en plupart des livres où vous
aurez cette petite x donc qui signifie
prise
freese a parfois il peut avoir quelques
à part deux points à la place mais c'est
rare est la place des donc moins de
l'obliger oui voilà et à savoir que
plupart des joueurs quand on joue on ne
remarque rien du tout parce qu'on devine
que c'est une prise donc parce qu'ils
ont personnellement j'aimerais grillage
et j'aurais marqué 110 x temps et 5 mai
d'un plupart des livres pouvaient
retenir cette marque donc voilà alors on
aurait même pu mettre un point
d'exclamation ans voire même deux
puisque c'est un très bon coup c'est le
coup qui fait math regarder le roi noir
et m'a tout de suite puisque la dame
fait échec au roi qu'on peut mettre
aucune pièce entre le roi et la lame
aucune pièce ne peut aller en sur la
case de 6 on peut pas prendre la dame
aucune pièce cette emprise est alors le
roi ne peut aller nulle part puisque en
8 il est toujours en échec par la dame
en d6 il est toujours en échec par la
dame ainsi quand m6
il est en prise au prochain coup qu'ils
fassent donc ses échecs et mat la partie
s'arrête alors on va revenir maintenant
sur le deuxième coup après damas cinq on
voit que donc il des parenthèses ici qui
sont ouvertes deux parenthèses bilité
donc dans les notations ça veut dire
voilà une possibilité qui n'a pas été
joué dans la partie le coût qualité
jouer c'est bien le coup combien de voir
deux coups au 3e set
qu'est-ce qu'il ait marqué en gras et en
parenthèse on montre une variante ce
qu'on appelle une variante d'offre le
d'échec alors deuxième coup des blancs
alors nc le l'appareil c'est le sait la
signification anglaise night
en français on aurait mis c'est le n
veut dire en anglais night comme
chevalier en fait et donc ça signifie
lecavalier en fait cavalier alors ça
veut dire cavaliers sur la case f3 ci
avait pas eu le nc aurait été le pion
qui serait venu sur la case d3 voyez le
pion il ya trois pièces qui peuvent
aller sur la case f3 ici soit le pion f2
à f3 soit le cavalier g11 françois
éventuellement la dame pour revenir
aussi sur la case f 33 donc alors après
un e 4 e 5 au lieu du coup deux dames h5
ont choisi le coup knight f3 donc
cavalier sur la case istres en voilà le
volet l'ine alors la réponse des noirs
oui ces cavaliers no6 sur la casse c'est
6 alors a b c 2 3 4 5 6 et cette case là
quelques cavaliers pelé sur cette case y
en a qu'un c'est celui ci puisque
l'autre est beaucoup trop loin
donc il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté c'est bien
cavaliers c6 troisième coup des blancs
alors en français ça aurait été un f ici
c'est en anglais mais on comprend vite
puisque le b s'avère bishop en anglais
c'est bien le fou un plus et la slps qui
était allé sur cette case
voilà fou sur la case ici c4 alors a b c
2 3 4 c'est cette case
c'est ce foulard sont l'autre fou il est
enfermé voyez c'est assez facile en
général pas se tromper
surtout avec les fous de toute façon
puisque il y en a eu sur 15 novembre sur
4 blanc que l'on peut pas se tromper
c'est une case blanche dans sa peut être
que celui ci donc ce fou doit venir sur
la case c4
et voilà c'est effectivement le coup
qu'ils aient joué alors les noirs
répondre par le coup fous ces cinq c'est
pareil on voit du monde qu'on a trouvé
la casse et quatre places et 5 n'est pas
difficile à trouver quel est le fou qui
peut y aller évidemment c'est le fouet
fuite qui peuvent venir sur cette case
donc fou c'est 5
oui c'est très simple on continue la
partie donc voyez voilà ici n qu'on vous
avez compris c'est le monde les knights
et 3 regardez c'est la case ici ab c'est
donc colonnes c est un deux trois c'est
bien la case ici ces trois voiliers que
je vois bien la bataille navale et vous
ai tout de suite que les autres
cavaliers detroit il peut pas venir sur
7 3 6 pas celui-là pas si loin de
fonctions pas comme ça voilà donc c'est
bien celui-ci cavaler ces trois là on
continue
regardez la partie donc les noirs
répondent par le coup cavaliers f6 donc
c'est bien la case m6 ici knight et 6
voilà c'est bien notre cavalier ce qu'il
veut sur l'a46 et alors la maintenance
et ninon qu'est ce que c'est cette jeune
coiffeuse 0 0 alors que 0 0 ça veut dire
quoi
et donc voilà c'est une annotation
spécial ça veut dire rocco petty rock
petit rond à retenir d'un goût fait 0-0
sensing fait péter rock alors que
bourgoin rock au mois dé sainte rose
allait voir plus tard ont valsé sera 0-0
3-0 3-0 d'où tirez voilà donc 00 petit
rock triple zéro grand roque
effectivement on voit bien que les
blancs peuvent faire le rock c'est le
coût qui est proposé enfin c'est le coût
qui est marqué dans la variante donc
petit rock
maintenant les noirs répondre par des
six rondes et il n'y a pas de pièces
marquées devant des six donc c'est un
pion sur la case dessinons seul le four
et plus ne soit quasi mais ya pas marqué
food et 6 il aurait marqué f
ou plutôt b en anglais ici mais f en
france et donc des six c'est bien le
pion 17 qui vient sur la classe des 6,6
des trois de la même façon les blancs
jouent le coup des deux des trois le
pion 2d vient sur la classe des trois
puisqu'il n'y a pas de pièces marquées
au 6e coup les noirs répondre ici par le
coup bishop angers quatre fous ans j'ai
quatre enfants s'est endormi réf
le fou c'est 8 vient sur la case ici g4
je vous rappelle
1 2 3 4 5
pardon a b c d e f g 1 2 3 4 c'est cette
case la foulée 4 voilà donc c'est facile
les blancs répondre maintenant par sept
par le coup fou bishop sur la case de 3
alors la case 3 c'est bien a b c d e f a
b c d e pardon 1 2 3 c'est cette case là
donc c'est bien ce fou c'est un qui
vient sur la case de trois et on marque
regardez ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
point d'exclamation donc ça veut dire
que c'est un coût plutôt bon tout ce qui
démarque au point d'exclamation c'est
plutôt bon suivi d'un point
d'interrogation donc bon mais un tout
petit peu douteux on dit que c'est
intéressant
c'est intéressant c'est pas forcément
vous ne laissez plus tard vraiment un
coup intéressant c'est un coup
intéressant là les noirs répondent par
le coup fou prend 1 donc toujours le
multiplier prend la case 3 donc là par
contre marqué avec un point
d'interrogation plutôt un goût douteux
alors pourquoi doute est ce pour des
raisons stratégiques parce que les
blancs répondent ici par le coup f alors
f prend 2,3 donc ça c'est un peu
différent c'est pas un grand f
voyez donc ce n'est pas un fou ça veut
dire que c'est une pièce qui se trouve
sur la colonne f alors a b c d e f
qu'est ce qui se trouve sur la colonne
est fait qui peut aller en 3 c'est bien
le pion donc ça veut dire c'est le pion
de la colonne f qui peut aller de 3
donc vous l'avez vous remarqué la
différence de vraiment il faut bien
marqué un petit ou grand l'être parce
que ça peut changer tôt là c'était un
grand lettre c'était en français ça donc
déjà fou et 3 à la place
et puis on prend les trois bien sûr donc
là c'est un petit temps que ces petits c
soit une colonne ranger son avion voilà
donc f prend à eux trois les non
répondent par queen 17,1 queen 17 donc
daems et dante c'est donc la dame des 8
vient sur la case 17 ici voilà c'est le
coup les fronts maintenant les blanches
à dire les français les blancs répondent
par le coup rd tarn eu la casse 2e ainsi
celle-ci donc effectivement la dame ici
peut venir sur la case et là on a le
fameux camp rock dont tu as parlé tout à
l'heure
grand rectangle avouerez tenais comment
marquer camargue avec très simple avec
donc le relais 0 voilà si on avait
regardé
rôles et noir peuvent faire 2 de rock le
petit de ce côté là où le grand du grand
côté le roi se déplace toujours de deux
cases mais pour distinguer les deux et
bien ici on met triple zéro donc ça veut
dire qu'il va rentrer de ce côté là si
on avait mis que 2 0 ils auraient rauque
et de l'autre côté voilà donc ça a été
le choix des noirs les choix aux rockets
de ce côté là donc j'espère aux a bien
compris comment une marque et c'est
assez simple on terminé pour repérer
avec un joli exemple matin très
populaire avec on va vous montrer le mât
du berger qui m'a très populaire ici on
a vu une première variante avec deux
cavalières 3 est toujours dans les
parenthèses on a une deuxième variante
avec toujours le devrions dire on
retrouve bien le deuxième coup donc il
faut remettre la position à la fin du
premier coup voyez on remet la position
la fin du premier coup on revient ici
dans la deuxième variante qui propose et
là on a vu une première variante la
deuxième ronde ces dames f3 et là vous
remarqué à quel point c'est important de
numéroter les coûts parce que si on
n'avait pas ici mido est par exemple
quand c'est marqué on n'aura pas compris
dans quel moment on doit faire cette
alternative
oui c'est très important que vous
marquez ou bien à deux ou trois terrains
voilà exactement pour savoir que de
quelques où il s'agit dans la partie ou
dans la variante qui proposait donc on
propose un fait c'est toujours une
variante qui propose deux dames f3 les
noirs répondre par le coup cavaliers à
nice en anglais cavaliers sur la casse
ces six donc c'est toujours c'est cette
case là donc qu'avait laissé six
lecavalier b8 ici vient sur la casse et
6 les blancs font le coup ces quatre
coups qu'on a déjà vu vous et 4 facile
hélas les noirs jouent le coup end et 4
donc si vous dire night des quatre
cavaliers sur la case des quatre la case
des cats et celle ci effectivement le
cas au lycée 6 peuvent venir sur la case
des 4 avec deux points métal rock
intégrant qui veut dire une gaffe comme
on l'a dit tout à l'heure de pointe en
cas ça veut dire être très mauvais comme
on veut et encore plus mauvais vraiment
donné deux fois mauvais pourquoi deux
fois mauvais et bien parce que les
blancs répondent par un bon coup voyez
kim noter ici par une un point
d'exclamation c'est le coup regardez
dame prend prend le multiplient fowler
prend la case f7 et on voit bien matt
marqué ici le dièse ça veut bien dire
matt point d'exclamation bon coup
effectivement la dame peut venir prendre
la case et 7 et on vérifie bien c'est
matt pourquoi parce que le roi noir est
en échec de la dame évidemment on peut
pas prendre la dame n'y a pas de case
entre le roi la dame on peut rien m et
on ne peut pas prendre la dame f7
pourquoi mais tout simplement parce que
le fou ces quatre pattes a créé le roi
donc le roi se mettraient en échec c'est
pas possible et la case de sète n'est
pas non plus disponible puisque la dame
fait échec donc voilà le roi noir était
celle qui peut pas par et l'échec ses
échecs et mat fait la partie victoire
des blancs donc on peut même remarquer
d'ailleurs le score en général on met un
zéro quand c'est aux élèves qui gagne
oui avec tes répète cyr et au milieu on
y va en principe ou deux points plutôt
cessera 1-0 a signifié aux télés plein
gagné au contraire 0 petit tiré un
excellent et noir qui ont gagné voilà
donc un zéro et donc les blancs gagne
0,1 et noir et un demi quand on vient de
me ça veut dire effectivement partie nul
j'aurais obtenu un huitième point
facilement compris voilà donc vous
pouvez revoir cette émission calmement
suite à ça vous aurez sans doute aucun
souci maintenant pour lire une partie
d'échecs avec ses commentaires et
remarques et peut-être vos propres
partis est marquée au propre parti
fictivement si vous jouez face à un
adversaire c'est une façon aussi de
marquer votre parti est de pouvoir
rejouer après pour l'analyse et
éventuellement donc vous pourrez mettre
vos analyses entre parenthèses écrire
des livres jeunesse et on va devenir un
très grand écrivain
on peut noter des grands livres de
shericka williams et 60 meilleures
parties de bobby fischer oui il ya le
bréviaire des échecs de tartas cover oui
on peut citer quoi stein l'art du combat
c'est sa mère du fondeur aux échecs le
tournoi zurich 1900 quand on conseille
donc tous ses livres ou peut-être pour
vous pour l'instant si vous êtes
débutant quelque chose de plus simple
encore alors il ya aussi les livres
historiques comme l'analyse de jeu
d'échecs par louis andré danican
philidor qui date de 1820 même de 1700
et quelques donc voilà des très vieux
livre aussi où vous allez retrouver des
alors des notations un peu anciennes
mais on va retrouver des concepts
équivalent en tout cas à partir
d'aujourd'hui tous ces possibilités sont
au vert pour vous alors allez-y et pour
saisir cette opportunité
voilà et pour lire vos parties d'échecs
que ce soit sur des niveaux sur internet
voilà donc c'est fini pour cette leçon
spéciale notation du jeu d'échecs et
vous vous la remet pour lire toute la
littérature égyptienne il ya là beaucoup
merci nino derian revoir au revoir
[Musique]